من المتوقع ان يكون لنتائج انتخابات
التجديد النصفي في الكونجرس تاثيرات على
قضايا متعلقه بسياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
اذا سيطر الجمهوريون على احد المجلس
الساين او على كليهما فتغيره توازن القوى
داخل المؤسسه التشريعيه سيصاحب على
الاداره الامريكيه اتخاذ بعض القرارات
ابرز القضايا العوده الى الاتفاق النووي
مع ايران الذي يرفضه الجمهوريون بالاجماع
باعتباره ضعيفا ولا يخدم مصلحه الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها في الشرق الاوسط
المتحفظين عليه لكونه لا يعالج سلوك ايران
المزعزي على الاستقرار والامن حيث يتعهد
الجمهوريون بعرقله الاتفاق اذا لم يطرح
على الكونجرس لمراجعته او يقرر كم معاهده
لكن عرقله الاتفاق تتطلب اغلبيه الثلثين
في المجلسين اي 67 صوتا في مجلس الشيوخ
ومئتين صوتا في مجلس النواب ومن غير
المرجح اذا فاز الجمهوريون ان يحصل على
هذه الارقام فعدد الديمقراطيين الرافدين
للاتفاق لا يعوض نقص
لا يمكن للجمهوريين اذا حققوا انتصارا في
الانتخابات النصفيه ان يمنع الاداره من
العوده الى خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
فموجب التشريع الذي تم تمريره عام 2015
ويسمى اينار لا تحتاج الاداره الى تصويت
ثلاثي الاعضاء وهم يتطلبه اقرار معاهده
دعم اوكرانيا هو الاخر يشهد مزيدا من
التحفظ عليه اذا فاز الجمهوريون فصحيح انه
يلقى تايدا واسعا من الحزبين لكن هناك
معارضه متزايده له في الحزب الجمهوريه
بسبب التكلفه غير المسبوقه خاصه في ظل
التضخم في الصلب هذه المعارضه تيار ترامب
الانعزاليه الداعي الى التركيز على الشؤون
الداخليه بدلت تدخلات الخارجيه ومن ابرز
المؤيدين السنه جورج هولي والسيناتور
رانبول اللذان صوت ضد المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا
في مجلس النواب وفي مجلس الشيوخ الذين
يريدون فقط رؤيتها بعيدا يواجه مشاكل
الامور عليه لكن بصراحه لا ارى تهديدا
خطيرا لاستمرار دعم الولايات المتحده
الاوكرانيا
بعض الجمهوريين يدعون الى انفاق الاموال
في مواجهه الصين بدل اوكرانيا وهنا يبرز
ملف دعم تايوان حيث كان لافتا تاييد 26
عضوا جمهوريا في مجلس الشيوخ لزياره رئيسه
مجلس النواب الديمقراطيه نانسي بيلوسي الى
الجزيره حسين الروض العربيه واشنطن